[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
through the years hundreds of thousands
of kids have laced up their skates on
the ponds and lakes that dot the great
state of minnesota
one month from now it'll be the
minnesota wild on the outdoor ice
against the st louis blues
so join us on the road to the 2022 nhl
winter classic
here we go
yeah yeah yeah i go
for st louis blues captain ryan o'reilly
another nhl season is underway
just like that
i feel great you know you're the best
player honestly i think the underpriced
score 50 possibly 60 this year
but this one has something special for
him and his blues to look forward to
it's o'reilly's second appearance in an
nhl winter classic on new year's day
come on you're faster than that
and this time he'll get to experience it
with his family by his side
all right we're going to race to the
door
me versus you on your mark
get set
go go
oh i'm gonna get you i'm gonna get you
come on
[Music]
the winter classic is something special
it takes you back to when your kid
you're out there and you got the glare
the the wind the sun your toes are numb
it's gonna be a great game
whoa that blistering shot
got your shot just like your old man
last time he was in one it was
seven days after jamison our first son
was born so we never got to go so
they're so excited that and i'm excited
too to go take your time
i think once you kind of have kids it
completely changes everything oh
my goodness what a shot one goal
good shot buddy before then you come
home you think about the game constantly
and when you come through that door and
they see and they come around they don't
care how you play it or if you want or
lost it's amazing that way how it they
just help you forget everything that's
going on and keep you in the moment and
it's something that's so so special and
you cherish
is that your ball
wow whoa good dribbling she usually
takes me down to basketball
the one thing i can beat him in five
lives
oh
no no no whoever misses loses
[Music]
oh oh
oh
that's it you won
oh oh oh all you wanted yeah
oh i won
unfortunately that's not the first time
she's beat me there
ah and on camera too declan
[Music]
all right the blues at ten seven and
three that is still good enough for a
tie for second place in the central they
come in tonight trailing the minnesota
wildly four points
you know being a captain to me it's a
responsibility i think i do talk quite a
bit in the room i try to lead by example
come on boys right away here right away
let's have a start boys hey right away
i got a map
same time it's challenging i got to
constantly get out of my comfort zone
finding new ways to push and be
responsible for everyone let's build it
up here let's get something going here
saint louis is coming off two
consecutive losses and tonight again
starts off disappointing for the blues
who trail one nothing after one period
guess what they're going the other way
every time they're going to beat us up
the ice get your [ __ ] together let's
dominate them mr kirk
that's not good enough i had all the
work going and we start like that
really are we kidding ourselves
skate work
let's go
here we go big ten on you
let's go boys hey let's go
[Music]
you know his message got us going wraps
it around how much damage they score
it wasn't just a few guys there's
everyone
a six to three win ends the short losing
streak a momentary bump in the road for
a team with higher aspirations whatever
the coach said after the first period it
works there's so many pieces here when
we do things the right way you see how
effective it is and we can play with any
team there's a feeling that you know
this can be something special and it's
exciting